próximo estamos en navidad entonces este
es el último programa antes de las
navidades les agradecemos muchísimo de
estar acompañándonos como siempre a
nosotros a través de youtube facebook
también en el cnt puntos sea y como
entonces lo dije al inicio este es el
programa del castor cibernético estamos
un equipo muy reducido hoy pero o cuán
fuerte y podemos hablar tres días
bienvenidos estamos aquí pues ya en la
víspera de navidad y parece que este año
no va a haber una navidad blanca que es
lo que está pasando afuera
de todo canadá si hay unas temperaturas
irregularmente altas para la temporada
atrás y regularmente baja para todos
sí sí bueno pero lo peor dentro de eso
no es que las temperaturas sean altas
sino que está lloviendo está lloviendo
muy suelto cuando las temperaturas suben
ya no nieva
está lloviendo acá pero en el oeste
canadiense ya hay 2 centímetros de
espesor de hielo por la lluvia helada
que eso nosotros nos salvamos parece sí
exacto pero subió la temperatura rápido
entonces con las lluvias se fué
descongelando pero anoche yo salí a
tirar el reciclaje a las horas de la
noche y estaba a eso le tengo un terror
que para parar a los aquellos nos
escuchan y no saben de qué estamos
hablando es que en el invierno acá no
sólo cae nieve que es una cosa hermosa
cuando cae liviana y uno sale a jugar y
canta y hacerlos lindas bío y es hermoso
pero también cae lluvia helada es decir
una lluvia pesada que si hielo en
realidad cae al contacto con colonias o
se congela bueno y entonces se hace una
capa de hielo bueno en el caso hubo en
el 98 97 98 90
de agua helada y se habían formado hasta
el 45 centímetros
no todas pero una buena parte de las
torres de alta tensión pues que no
pudieron resistir el peso también habían
de ellos de kansas techos de casas que
no pudieron resistir el peso y se
vinieron abajo también no sí sí no fue
un desastre porque aparte bueno no había
el eje de energía eléctrica ni a que las
casas te diría que un 60 por ciento
están con el energía eléctrica para
acercarlas fraccionadas entonces en ese
caso había que ir a casa de gente que
tuviera otro tipo de calefacción porque
no se podía calefaccionar la vivienda
exactamente esto es mucho más suave
sobre todo aquí creo que en montreal
está suave es pura lluvia pero esa
lluvia también trae consecuencias creo
que hablan de 40 centímetros a 50
entonces también empieza el desborde de
los ríos ya nosotros y las personas que
viven en abajo digamos el puesto hay
peligros serios de inundaciones entonces
no es una buena manera de festejar
navidad y parece que mañana sábado va a
nevar y después de esos
las heladas entonces disfrutemos tan
feliz 11 grados eso es un récord aquí
está en esta época exacto pero mira yo
suelo venir siempre en bicicleta
hoy no me animé porque estaba lloviendo
tanto y como decían hablábamos de la
lluvia helada en bicicleta tampoco es el
mejor momento para andar polar porque
hablarle hay otra de las grandes
particularidades canadienses es que se
genera el hielo negro
esos son como fragmentos de hielo que
están tan bien disimulados
0 - lumbre entonces generar así deuda me
acuerdo me acuerdo de tu de tu accidente
también entonces la gente no lo ve y
realmente hay un
una discriminación de accidentes y y en
esta época sube la cantidad de gente que
va a las emergencias los hospitales por
si aún así no nos sigue en serio en todo
caso por ahora la estamos pasando bien
es lluvia entonces no es esta lluvia
helada que causa tantos accidentes y no
es por nada que las personas de la
tercera edad que ya no son de la tercera
juventud esa es otra historia se van a
vivir durante todos los meses de
invierno en florida hay un lugar que
dicen los llaman el que de que es y por
lo que es de los que se llaman los
pájaros
madrugadores o algo así
porque son los primeros que sirve la
flor y el frío y se instala ya por seis
meses llevan sus casas rodantes se
alquilan los terrenos para poner su casa
rodante la pasan muy bien y siguiendo
buenas fiestas pablo hablamos un poquito
la semana anterior a la otra ya no
recuerdo muy bien pero creo que es un
tema que hay que hay que conversarlo un
poco para aquellos que nos están
escuchando sobre todo acá en canadá es
que entra ya entró en vigor una nueva
disposición del código criminal con
respecto al alcohol al volante y como
esta época es de mucho alcohol entonces
de qué se trata esto que entró ahora en
vigencia y bueno está este cambio al
código criminal no respecto al alcohol
entró en vigencia este martes 7 de
diciembre exacto y bueno hay que
recordar antes de lanzarnos que ya el
código criminal había sido modificado
había sido cambiado por cuando entró en
vigencia
el 17 de octubre como ustedes recordarán
la legalización de la mayoría de la
marihuana
entonces se agregó al código criminal el
consumo de marihuana como infracción si
te encuentran pues que estás fumado
conduciendo tu carro tu vehículo pues te
pueden multar entonces ya hubo un primer
cambio en la ley lo que se come en lo
que respecta a la marihuana sí y el
cambio que entró en vigencia hoy acá es
con respecto al alcohol entonces quiere
decir que antes cuando y sobre todo para
este período
las fiestas por todos lados y bueno y la
gente pues a veces se le va la mano con
el alcohol se lleva la boca y también
entonces
antes de que se modificará el código
criminal
un policía por ejemplo podía detenerte
legalmente en el sentido si hay un
tienes una luz quemada en fin algo que
no tiene nada que ver con el alcohol la
policía te para y si antes de que se
modificara la ley si tú habías consumido
alcohol la policía no podía obligar
obligarte a pasar el alcotest
ahora sí ahora sí con esta nueva ley
antes antes podía hacerlo pero tenía que
tener una razón muy válida para exigirle
a la persona que pasará a la corte bueno
yo me acuerdo apenas llegué yo a canadá
hace 15 años atrás aproximadamente me
paro y vamos con un par de amigos y con
mi hermano iba manejando volvíamos de
una despedida de soltero mi hermano muy
correctamente ha viajado a tomar como a
las 11 de la noche eran como las 3 de la
mañana y sin embargo andrew cowles no
había un control policial pero un
control solamente para algo test o sea
que cuando se hacía un control
específicamente para eso si tenían
dinero
porque si yo estaba decidido que era
para el alcotest ag pero puedes tener un
faro quemado puedes tener una luz que no
funciona
en ese momento exigir de hoy si eso es
lo nuevo es lo nuevo es que ahora sí
pueden inmediatamente pasar el alcotest
y ese es el cambio digamos en términos
legales
es bastante importante aquellos que nos
están escuchando acá de la comunidad
latinoamericana en cualquier lugar en
canadá pues están muy atentos a tratar
de no infringir esa regla porque las
multas son muy elevadas y el alcotest da
positivo
aparte si uno reincide después les sacan
el carné de conducir
que te paran y que tiene cometen una
infracción quieran estando todos aquí
tenemos 12 puntos creo en 15 puntos de
15 puntos ahora entonces cada vez que
cometen una infracción que que más una
luz roja que pasa con esto
a cuatros puntos ya no puedes conducir
más cuando uno empieza con 15 puntos y
le va sacando 1 todavía pues conduce sí
sí y cuando recuperas esos puntos ya no
será igual en américa latina' usted se
acuerde nos vamos a preguntarle a
nuestros oyentes cómo funciona este
mundo si existe el sistema de punta
para los permisos de conducir en qué
punto son tiempo cuántos punto y cuánto
tiempo hay para recuperar el carné de
conducir en todo caso si el sector
ahora vamos a conversar de otro tema que
esta semana también a mí me llamó la
atención es una familia venezolana que
tiene una orden de expulsión de canadá
después de estas fiestas después del
primer del primero de enero de 2019 esta
semana me acuerdo que luis laborda había
hecho una nota sobre una familia
colombiana aquí en montreal la familia
montoya repulsión
a la orden de expulsión ya habían
comprado los pasajes están obligados a
comprar los pasajes tenían todo pero
hubo end y son de montreal a ese años
que estaban acá su demanda de solicitud
de refugio fue rechazada y a último
momento intervino el ministro de la
inmigración y les dio un año y medio de
permiso de trabajo y que continúa su
vida hasta que se analice nuevamente su
caso lo cual me parece bastante positivo
tienen muchas posibilidades de rever
también la situación y de ver que si hay
alguna cosa que no está en orden que la
puedan corregir el tema es que éste se
demoran tanto se demoran tanto en
analizar en migraciones estos casos que
la gente se va casando tiene hijos y
profesionales van trabajando como
cualquiera y esto le pasó y lo triste es
a esta familia rodríguez bonito que son
de venezuela están viviendo en winnipeg
llegaron en el 2015 bueno es una familia
que ya está integrada también a la
comunidad en winnipeg entonces se están
movilizando hay un organismo de derechos
humanos canadiense que está
por ellos hay un sacerdote entonces
bueno se están movilizando es una pareja
con una hija que llegaron de venezuela
por motivos políticos pidieron refugio
entonces lo triste de todo esto es que
si no pasa nada de ellos ya compraron
los boletos también porque tienen esa
opción o compras voz el boleto y te vas
o te expulsan y la opción tiene que ver
te conozco en caso de una persona que le
dieron cuando uno se compra uno mismo el
boleto
la multa entre comillas para poder
volver a acceder a canadá es menor si yo
me pagó el boleto lo mismo yo dentro de
un año puedes al hospital de 9 avenida
exacto si yo no me lo pago son 10 años
de inquietud te vayas de forma
voluntaria cuando te dicen que tienes
que ir y te vas y cuando te tienen que
expulsar es decir que te obligan que
tiene que ir a buscarte las autoridades
de inmigración al aeropuerto
y eso entonces implica que cuando web
quieras regresar si te lo permiten va a
ser más complicado ahora esta familia
que estamos mostrando estamos mostrando
esto están en la familia en realidad el
señor rodríguez bonito vino con su
esposa y su hija pero ellos ya tienen un
hermano en winnipeg que está desde los
años 70 con su esposa y la hermana de
este señor ya obtuvo la inmigración
legal
dice un familiar pero es vertical de la
reunificación familiar y padre-hijo
exacto
los refugiados como inmigrantes como
inmigrante y lo que hace lo que lo que
hizo mi hermano en el momento fue una
carta de recomendación y avalando
digamos dejando abierta la posibilidad
de que si yo no tenía donde quedarme
podría quedarme lo de él pero no tenía
ningún tipo de obligación para con mi
inmigración está bien
pero en el caso de la gente que hace la
vertical uno tiene la obligación de
sostener a la persona que está ayudando
a venir
durantes yo creo que son tres años
aproximadamente puede ser que te haces
cargo hasta que la persona logre un sí
bueno acá no sólo vino a vino esta
familia sino además la trajo a la madre
y la trajo
a otra persona más de la familia y bueno
ellos compraron el pasaje ahora no
quieren regresar a venezuela y él es de
origen brasileño tiene una parte de la
familia en portugal entonces sacaron
boletos a portugal pero es como empezar
otra nueva vida y es todo lo que implica
llevar a la familia ahora otro tema que
yo creo que es súper interesante lo que
está pasando con este muchacho marcado y
que ya dejó de ser un niño pablo en dos
años treinta y dos presente niño que hoy
obtener un pasaporte canadiense durante
trágica no exactos y bueno hay que
recordar que omar khadr cuando tenía 15
años y un poco más joven se fue a
afganistán su padre una parte de su
familia estaba viviendo ahí
él vivía en toronto y su padre de origen
y este niño se encontraba ahí y se metió
con él es un padre el que lo involucró
en afganistán con la lucha armada
entonces se le acusa de haber lanzado
una granada que provocó la muerte de un
soldado estadounidense él tenía 15 años
entonces hay varios debates alrededor de
esto porque bueno lo trasladaron a la
cárcel de guantánamo que ese es el
principal tema diez años de teniendo
niño estamos hablando de un niño que
exacto de 15 años que lo apresaron y lo
mandaron a la cárcel de guantánamo donde
pasó diez años y vino y es torturado y
un montón de cosas en guantánamo cambio
de un niño entonces ese será el caso a
un caso internacional y es que el
gobierno canadiense no se había
movilizado mucho tampoco para traerlo a
canadá como hicieron otros países que
sacaron a sus prisioneros de guantánamo
cando
y finalmente el gobierno canadiense en
el 2017 luyn de mi show después de
haberlo repatriado lo indemnizó y le
pagaron creo que son 10 millones de
dólares algo así por eso pero bueno a él
le dieron una libertad condicional pero
estás viviendo en montarme en la
provincia así entonces la semana pasada
justamente ya habíamos hablado que se
había presentado con su abogado ante el
tribunal de la reina el tribunal de la
reina como le dicen en el montón en la
alberta y él pide que se suavicen un
poco las restricciones que todavía se
aprecian sobre él aunque esté en
libertad porque tiene una libertad bajo
fianza pero entre otras cosas no puede
viajar sin autorización ni del gobierno
canadiense para salir del país ni de la
provincia de alberta para para
desplazarse él tenía sus audiciones en
toronto por ejemplo entonces cuando ya
de alberta ontario de tenía que pedirle
permiso a las autoridades de la
provincia para poderse desplazar
entonces que tenía muchas restricciones
por eso está pidiendo él está pidiendo
el pasaporte bueno que se suavice en
esas restricciones y que no tenga que
estar pidiendo permisos y si quiere
desplazar de una ciudad a otra y que se
le permita tener un pasaporte canadiense
porque él es musulmán y él quiere hacer
la peregrinación que es obligatoria por
lo menos una vez en la vida para todos
buen musulmán él quiere hacer eso pero
para poder hacerlo tiene que tener un
pasaporte que todavía no lo tiene
entonces la semana pasada
es que el pp quiere que poder hablar con
su hermana célestin absolutamente
prohibido sus hermanas vive en eeuu y se
le tiene absolutamente prohibido
cualquier contacto con su hermana
telefónico personal entonces él quiere
también que se le permita hablar con su
hermano y él hizo ese pedido la semana
pasada
en el mismo tribunal y se va a decidir
si se le suavizan las condiciones y si
se le va a otorgar el pasaporte si podrá
finalmente comenzar una nueva vida
exactamente él dice que cada día que
pasa él se siente como si estuviera
todavía funciones o sea sufriendo lo que
suscriben
con las restricciones que tenían bueno
pero psicológicamente cuando te dejo el
chico de 15 años que te liberan a los 25
que te torturan y todo lo demás tienen
suicidio
no no no la marca es absolutamente
legítima no debe haber sido fácil de más
de versión posible no querría estar en
su piel pero independientemente de eso
no es lo mismo que estar en guantánamo
cuando sabemos efectivamente en realidad
tampoco sabemos demasiado lo que pasa en
guantánamo está bien ya me parece que es
lógico que le den por lo menos la
posibilidad de viajar y de verse con su
familia y no necesariamente porque
además no
con la con el tema del pasaporte se hace
un poco más complejo porque bueno
volviendo a
a viajar a los lugares donde podría
haber conexiones con probablemente la
justicia dará su veredicto
exactamente seguir tengo aquí se luego
gente que está conectada con nosotros ya
guild en abril
con o sin nieve dice bonito con nieve
esta opina que es más bonito también
todos estamos ayudado también lo que sea
un abrazo desde cap l entonces en abril
javier gonzález nunca hay feliz navidad
y un muy buen año nuevo con mucho éxito
para todos ustedes nrc y en las américas
elena pitos que dice felices fiestas
para todo el equipo de radio y j
leves que dice feliz navidad a todas ya
todos así que le retribuimos el saludo a
todos ya los que van a estar con
nosotros después en el programa nrc y
net punto o sea van también saludos que
no nos están acompañando en este momento
hay otro tema que yo destacó que es un
tema bastante triste que sucede
esto en columbia británica una niña de 6
años que estaba jugando en la escuela
primaria mi primer grado jugando en un
patio con los otros niños de la escuela
se acercó un señor no se sabe que le
dijo se la llevó la violentó sexualmente
y la trajo de vuelta a la escuela y la
dejó en el patio de vuelta entonces hay
un policía de la real policía montada de
canadá que es uno de los más grandes
investigadores en temas de abusos de
predadores sexuales contra los niños que
está dando alguna ayuda y dice cómo hay
que hacer para que los niños no caigan
en manos de depredadores es una
entrevista que pasó en exhibición y él
dice que que lo que es interesante de
este hombre es que él dice qué tipo de
niños buscan los depredadores no son o
no es cualquier niño y que además dice
que estos depredadores en general cuando
lo vio lo encuentran al niño oa la niña
que ellos quieren le dan un seguimiento
es decir no es una cosa así expone
largas
y lo que dicen dice entre otras cosas
que se buscan niñas tímidas las niñas
tímidas son candidatas para los
depredadores entonces lo que él dice que
una de las cosas muy importantes que
tienen que hacer los padres es hablar
con los niñitos a hablar con los niñitos
tener conversaciones abiertas dice no se
trata de asustarlos hart pero sí de
repetir esas conversaciones que le entra
en la mente de los niños sobre los
posibles escenarios que se pueden
producir con estos tipos y bueno dice
para y les aconseja a los niños una y
otra vez que escuchen a sus cuerpos y
que tienen derecho a decirle no a los
adultos y entonces les enseña como des
como como los padres tienen que
explicarle eso a los niños enseñarles
bueno que tienen el derecho de decir no
a los adultos hay que enseñarles a
gritar hay que enseñarles a hacer ruido
y hay que enseñarles a no ser
intimidados no tener miedo a este tipo
de personas da otro ejemplo por ejemplo
dice enseñarles a los niños una palabra
una contraseña que solamente lo saben el
niño la niña y los padres
es decir si hay un señor que se acerca y
dice que viene de parte de tu mamá de tu
papá porque tiene que llevarse con ellos
y la niña dice cuál es la contraseña que
ya pasó un caso hace poco la niña dijo
cuál es la contraseña y el señor el
depredador salió corriendo porque se dio
cuenta que podría haber un problema
entonces está dando este es lo que es
interesante de este policía de la real
academia es que quiere ayudar a los
padres y a los niños y entonces está
pues indicando cómo hacerlo bien pero
eso y decirle a los niños que bueno pues
no van a que no acepten ninguna
invitación de desconocido 116 la
historia siguiente y esto tiene que ver
con lo que se sabe lo poco que se sabe
de estos degenerados
van con animalitos a los parques te
atraen con eso lo que dice leonardo por
ejemplo y eso es algo cierto también a
los
niños chiquitos e incluso en los libros
de cuentos los monstruos son nosotros
habla de personas de monstruos son los
caricaturas caricaturistas caricaturiza
caricaturizan como monstruos cuando son
personas muy agradables en realidad que
saben cómo atraer a los niños son buena
gente entonces un niño piensan monstruo
piensan monstruos pero no ese señor que
le está sonriendo y entonces ahí es
donde y él dice que si se repite esas
conversaciones con los niños los niños
van eso incorporando eso y además
aprenden a gritar aprenden a gases ácida
del cielo no y si quieren la autora sí
sí sí y de chiquitos entonces dice si
necesita asustarlos pero hay que jugar
una situación donde se puede producir
eso y como enseñarles cómo reaccionar no
que es que es muy importante porque
estos problemas existen desde que la
humanidad existe entonces y lo que dicen
eso también es justamente es
estos depredadores estudian el espacio
donde está en una niña una vez que la
encuentran también piden a los vecinos
cuando ven eso que no duden en ir a la
policía aunque sea una falsa halaga
porque lo máximo que puede pasar es que
se equivoquen pero lo contrario también
es verdadera no se equivoquen entonces
cuando ven a un hombre merodeando por
ahí hay que prestarle atención
hay que estar alerta y ese es el mensaje
también para los adultos bueno en todo
caso vamos a tener música en el programa
desde ya les digo es este canadiense de
vancouver michael bublé
miguelito burbuja
también traducido pero es de justino
castor es justin bieber y miguelito
bubble semana y lito me miguelito por el
que está casado con una argentina
luisana
es una actriz argentina que estuvo
viviendo una tragedia también
su hijo según me dijo es activo en un
momento dado siendo muy chiquito un
cáncer feroz entonces él también cuenta
la historia de cómo eso le cambió su
vida
la enfermedad de su hijo y justamente el
es pues tiene para los que no lo conocen
es un cantante al estilo de frank
sinatra
un crooner que tiene una voz bien
particular porque además él hizo siempre
desde hace años hace canciones navideñas
que las canta como un crooner y
encontramos una canción que canta en
español entonces de la navidad así que
ahí está en el sitio de erese y net
punto sea para los que quieran escuchar
buena música navideña por el canadiense
michael bublé bubble entonces podemos ir
ahora con las cartas de nuestros oyentes
yo quiero oír una noticia insólita el
filial y también no le quiero dar mucho
tiempo pero rapidito la historia de este
hombre que se los conté o al principio
antes de venir
el presidente del deportes tolima
colombiano gabriel camargo afirmó este
jueves que la liga femenina de fútbol es
un caldo de cultivo para el lesbianismo
si siguen existiendo hombres y hombres
pobres y es una criatura que no es el
director técnico del equipo no es un
dirigente fue senador y eso es que es un
equipo del sur del país en un equipo
profesional que forma parte de que puede
en el torneo colombiano de fútbol y
finalmente si fuera verdad que dice lo
mismo no es rentable para los clubes y
que en este deporte las mujeres beben
más alcohol que los hombres pero en fin
esos sabes que es es ignorancia y seguro
se siente camargo no se olviden de dónde
vienen sus hijos dijo el edil le
contestó a alguien de una mujer o quiere
con futbolista le plancha la ropa y le
habló platicó
también es muy bien bueno
es de un levantador de pesas de la isla
del príncipe eduardo a la vecina de new
brunswick donde donde vive nuestra amiga
entonces es un pez y un levantador de
pesas no a manning que el 27 de octubre
pasado se levantó 260
y roger levantando los 260 kilos rompió
un récord mundial para t son 260 kilos
sí y lo levantó hasta el abismo
sí sí sí sí lo levantó él había primero
hecho un levantado 255 lo que quería él
su objetivo era romper un récord
nacional de canadá de canadá exacto
entonces él levantó 255 kilos y lo hizo
sin ningún problema después
son cuatro ensayos en el tercer ensayo
levanto 256 kilos y le quedaba un ensayo
dijo ah bueno porque no ponga ml 4 kilos
y entonces le pusieron 260 kilos y los
levantó maneje estaba muy contento
porque es lo que quiera romper un récord
nacional canadiense y resulta que en ese
torneo donde él estaba había alguien de
la federación de un árbitro
internacional caramba que estaba en el
lugar y que reconoció es reconocido como
los goles hemos logo pero el levantador
de pesas no sabía entonces semanas más
tarde él empieza a hacer una búsqueda en
internet porque quería
saber cuáles eran los estaba buscando un
nuevo objetivo no no se decía 260 pues
vamos a ver cómo estamos con los
objetivos y quienes lo tienen y todo lo
demás y hizo una búsqueda en internet y
se dio cuenta de que él era el campeón
mundial parecía ser campeón porque
realidad ahora tiene que hacer 261 para
160.5 y entonces era campeón mundial y
ni siquiera lo sabía lo supo semanas más
tarde que había un récord mundial que
qué premios recibes o no era una yo no
era una competencia internacional había
algo importante en juego
en el levantamiento de pesas no sé si
fuera atletismo digamos si rompes el
revés pero es que esto también existen
los buenos por ejemplo los olímpicos
este tipo de competición levanta pesas
pero no no creo que tenga una
remuneración por romper un récord no no
estoy muy seguro de esto si alguno de
los que nos está escuchando
puede haber algún tipo de remuneración
pero no tengo idea cuál lo que sí hacen
estos tipos de deportistas que no son
federados o que son federados pero que
él
porque no da tanto dinero como el tenis
el fútbol del basket ese tipo de
deportes lo que hacen es obtienen becas
y obtienen sponsors para presentarse en
los siguientes de eso viven de las becas
y de los sponsors entonces si él es
campeón es probable que le lluevan
ofertas de gente que quiere sponsorear
lo para los próximos olímpicos olímpicos
por ejemplo qué es lo que pasó con la de
esta chica olímpica levantadora de pesas
que le reconocieron le dieron todas las
becas y todo lo que conlleva haber
ganado la medalla en un olímpico claro
entonces no lo saben es una quebequense
canadiense que participó en los hondos
olímpicos de china también creció y como
hubo doping probado de las que estaban
antes que ella le fueron reconociendo y
subió y ganó la de oro
o la de bronce pero recibió 10 años
después la medalla de sharp muy bien e
interesante qué interesante ese caso
financiero es el tipo está muy contento
ahora mismo
tenemos otras ambiciones porque esto lo
puedes llevar por otros caminos los
olímpicos mismos representan a canadá a
quién sabe no estoy seguro que ya siendo
campeón en los olímpicos no sé si la
tendrá asegurada pero ya puede
participar de sí para qué bueno bueno
vamos a leer un poco los comentarios de
nuestros oyentes antes que protesten de
que nos olvidamos de leer entonces
leonardo bueno aquí tenemos el artista
juvenil asociada a deficiencia de
vitamina d según universidad de
saskatchewan y sirope ya camblor nos
dice muy importante que los médicos
pidan los valores de la vitamina d en
sangre se debe tener la cantidad justa
así como traer deficiencias cuando no
llega a los valores estándar no se debe
ingerir si no es necesario no es bueno
para el sistema circulatorio es libro
pella camblor quien nos manda este
mensaje y lo interesante perdón lo
interesante de su investigación
canadiense es que en realidad esa falta
de vitamina d todos sabemos también sé
por la falta de sol y esto es lo que
afecta más a los países nórdicos si
pablo si acá tengo la identidad twitter
inuit y el legado de la colonización
chocan en un nuevo documental anouk dice
buenísimo artículo y empleados de
correos de canadá declaran en huelga se
declaran en huelga en cuatro ciudades
del país
olivia ortiz nos dice en qué ciudades
hay huelgas eran todo el canal bien en
todo el canal y lo que hacían era que se
alternaban nunca decían todo el país
dos mujeres se tienen que seis ciudades
iba a llevar a cada sorpresa que la
sorpresa era que a último minuto de
antalya y en distintas ciudades de
canadá o sea no era en un solo en una
sola ciudad
en un solo conglomerado sino en varios
conglomerados decidían que no se iban a
repartir
por orden del gobierno federal los
obligaron pero aún así dicen que hay
como 6 millones o 4 millones de paquetes
cartas que se fueron acumulando y que no
creen que van a poder entregar
para las fiestas porque es a la gente
mandaba cosas para las fiestas
entonces tristemente algunos recibirán
los paquetes después de las fiestas
acá tengo un comentario sobre los
riesgos de los niños de la caravana de
migrantes en tijuana nos escriben
nuestro amigo de siempre javier gonzález
nungaray y dice creo y analizando este
artículo relacionado a los niños
migrantes en tijuana su situación física
y mental están en una posición muy
difícil el viaje desde su tierra el
trayecto hasta hasta tijuana porque
ponen tijuana bc
tijuana bc en dos veces y el roce con
diferentes personas requieren de
atención psicológica especial que bueno
que unicef interviene en este aspecto un
abrazo para todos en montreal desde
guadalajara méjico javier gonzález nunca
aray muchísimas gracias javier como
siempre y muchas felicidades
preguntémosle a javier justamente que
significa el este de tijuana tijuana bc
y lo pone con mayúsculas vece british
columbia
está en la frontera con eeuu aquí tengo
un mensaje sobre la noticia del tarot un
lenguaje del presente que descubre
potenciales juan enrique tomás garcía
nos dice yo me tiro el tarot para saber
del amor algunas veces más
y si me acierta pero todo depende de la
echadora de cartas dicen no creo que sea
ninguna estafa me han aceptado muchas
veces el problema es saber con quién te
vas a gastar el dinero pero hace una
amiga que no me cobra nada así
y ese era el mensaje entonces de juan
enrique tomás garcía acá tenemos los
músculos que no controlamos
conscientemente no sé si es una noticia
si es un reporte de lo hizo pero yo lo
dice por favor asegúrense de dar la
información correcta presentada en el
título o al menos cambien el título no
me cuentes o no sé por qué él hace esto
es creer eso yo lo y yo no podría haber
dado un poquito más de detalle al des de
explicar digo porque a veces uno ya es
lejano y no el tema está lejano y no se
acuerda y habla de los músculos que no
controlamos conscientemente
yo tengo acá dos cartas que llegaron de
cubo voy a nombrar solamente las
personas que no van dan es basilio
mendoza santos de ciego de ávila y
rafael reyes plaza desde santiago de
cuba muchísimas gracias por estos envíos
leonardo si tengo más noticias en este
caso cine canadiense le di la mano al
[ __ ] dice
la películas y renaldo acevedo dice
porque no puedo ver el vídeo sex and
with the es algo que me interesa para
ilustrar a otras personas inclusivas a
mis hijos sobre las barbaries que hace
el ser humano y de lo cual tenemos que
cuidarnos y nunca hacer la vista gorda
esto es el final de la acb
el romeo dallaire romeo dallaire el
famoso general romeo dallaire que estuvo
en la guerra comandaba en realidad las
fuerzas que se encontraban en ruanda en
el conflicto
en ese momento ruanda y eran los dos
países donde se entre mataban las
poblaciones y el leixóes butus y los
tutsis
y los tutsis exactamente y que salió muy
enfermo de ese lugar por todo lo que
había pasado y después pues incluso hubo
un intento de suicidio de esa parte y
han hecho una película y vivió primero
un libro cerraron el guión de la
película última entonces último
comentario pablo que tenga ahí que ve
que revise examen de licencia de
conducir para no
a los inmigrantes gladys peralta dice
soy ciudadana canadiense como prepararme
para conducir buses en la comunidad
urbana de montreal es una pregunta que
ya hace pero yo creo que directamente a
la comunidad urbana de montreal que
tendría que estar el bus el tipo tipo
stem la sociedad transporte moneda
tienen que hacer un curso para conducir
que lleva varios meses y después tienen
que rendir el tipo de carnet para poder
conducir ese tipo de buzos y es
colectivos escolares hoteles autogol
habla de la comunidad urbana de entonces
los autobuses los autobuses de la
comunidad urbana de montreal tiene los
buses estos que son como como
articulados que están larguísimos ese es
una conducción y tienen los otros buses
normales entonces pues hay todo una
serie de datos hay que yo creo que es en
el sitio de la comunidad urbana de
montreal ella puede encontrar el
perfecto ahora vamos a los temas que
durante la semana a leonardo gosh nos
hablas de lo más buscado en internet en
canadá es esto es google trends que es
el departamento de google que hace las
mediciones nos ofrece todos los años lo
más buscado y uno puede hacer digamos
elegir qué es lo que quiere ver yo en
este caso elegí lo más buscado en canadá
en distintas categorías y bueno para que
los que tengan tiempo y ganas de verlo
pueden ir a la página nuestra y van a
ver en cuanto a la noticia hemos buscado
en el país cuáles fueron las noticias
más buscadas las diez búsquedas top
sobre tecnología por ejemplo hoy en de
la reunida por miller categorías el como
en que las preguntas cómo se hace qué
edad tiene el príncipe harry pregunta la
pregunta del que tiene el principio
jardín qué edad tiene dolly partón esa
es otra de las que el tercero yo creo y
después de están las diez noticias
internacionales más buscadas en canadá
la principal fue la copa del mundo en
los juegos olímpicos
después los fallecidos durante el 2018
andoni board en el elche que se suicidó
año x space mike miller después el
séptimo arte lo más buscado en películas
primero en el 'top ten' está en pantera
negra
black panther la película de marvel y
después con información sobre músicos y
bandas personalidad y sociedad las
recetas por ella ganas de distraerse un
poco ahí tiene todo tipo de informe
exacto lo más buscado en canadá en el
año 2018 yo destacó un tema esta vez voy
primero que pablo siempre me pierdo
destacó así rapidito un tema que sé que
te quier ser y así más o menos que es
como una plataforma de traducción del
conocimiento respecto a evidencias en
materia de salud y es un proyecto muy
interesante es una asociación global
internacional que se originó aquí en
canadá en la universidad de alberta y en
la cual de la cual participan médicos
sudamericanos africanos por supuesto
canadienses
y respaldar colaboraciones basadas en
evidencia y también para intercambiar
conocimientos sobre prácticas y
estrategias y esto es lo interesante de
enfermedades no transmisibles ese es el
punto central de esta investigación y
sobre todo el acento está puerto en las
primeras naciones de canadá de américa
latina' de los países africanos y
nosotros conversamos con ulises panis et
que es un profesor en la universidad es
un médico y profesor de la facultad de
medicina de la universidad de minas
gerais donde pues estuvo explicando un
poco fue estuvieron reunidos en toronto
hubo como 25 profesionales que llegaron
a este encuentro para hablar de estas
enfermedades intercambio de conocimiento
de enfermedades no transmisibles que son
por ejemplo el cáncer que son las la
epidemia esta de cómo se llama cuando
falta el azúcar en la sangre tienes pero
elegantes en la diabetes ya ver que está
afectando muchísimo a las primeras
naciones canadienses en este caso pero
no solo las canadienses y ellos se
encuentran que éstas
enfermedades tienen puntos comunes en
todas las primeras naciones bueno esto
es lo que destaco yo y pablo descubren
que los efectos de antidepresivos pueden
transmitirse de una generación a otra y
pablo- entrevistaste a marilyn ver a
chang y es una investigación muy interés
muy interesante es una joven
investigadora de origen peruano de piura
me dijo ella muy muy contenta muy
orgullosa de su pura ella es bióloga y
se hizo esta investigación sobre los
peces cebra entonces la idea era que
estudiaron los efectos de la fluoxetina
que es un antidepresivo que comúnmente
conocido como prozac entonces utilizaron
prozac el efecto del prozac a largo
plazo con los empecé sage de varias
especies pero en particular en los peces
cebra y en el pez dorado y se dieron
cuenta
después de haber hecho la experiencia de
que él ve la fluoxetina y se transmite
de una generación a otra
entonces lo mismo podría pasar lo mismo
con los humanos lo interesante es el
punto central exacto que lo hicieron con
los peces y porque con los peces porque
la reproducción en los peces es mucho
más rápida para estudiar las
generaciones que con el ser humano que
cada nueve meses y después toma muchos
años entonces descubrieron eso es
interesante el estudio y bueno pues la
entrevista está en el rangers hectáreas
en net puntos y hay nosotros aquí sin
hablar felices fiestas dice sara villa
para todos ustedes y gracias por un año
maravilloso de canadá las américas de
rfc y gilberto martínez de feliz navidad
desde nicaragua también para todos
ustedes que nos han estado acompañando
todo
y vemos la próxima gracias